[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
Saguna miss bellum ah no
[Music]
My Love My Love 8000 BC is for you my
love my love my love
et voila or get a glass of vodka make
last oh boy get man for you Luna's don't
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my Sarah definitely NATO but a so beaten
abide by subito by a sous-vide alibi eat
your bear meat so female
[Music]
one morning I love companyís 1 the sivan
of on yard loopy bad kiss that all my
lovely metal it's a llama blah primero
que la la la
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the PM me get your it'll to yell at me
[Music]
[Music]
yah-yah-yah mozilla your No
Oh
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what we love the barrage Africa
[Music]
no pressure no they're to blame yarn or
Xavier you're nothing go Bonita let me
be the boy oh boy no sweet thumper
[Applause]
muslimeen ah muchas loves your no safety
thing I would tell me that it was yeah
thanks for monkey in a boat forgive us
yeah the hood
[Music]
support me
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
listen of anything can appear very
successful your little what can let you
place the para he let me know whenever I
know more about here
hi
[Music]
[Music]
I'm on my vo
[Music]
you know many
in a la una promesa yeah
[Music]
if we boil
[Music]
i'ma do
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
ah loosen your that's yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
um Luke Emily Gass tasty emphysema
Kirino he am kind of Kiera as their
market your different school I'm gonna
quiero escuchar
million only they qualcare mother cute
the cigarette Acadians au jus second
uncle who can rap AMISOM on man have to
cut in New Jersey they must see other
Sunday no malice prescient yes Milo for
the guess where a second Edwin Abu Dharr
get on your pull-ups perfect forget
handsome no makin a fool to know
perfectamente second owner CEO but IV
fellow tip whether said see the effect
yet oh baby me that my letter to the get
italic one single me do nastiness better
Julia to make you promote you could see
investing me more can do camara
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
nobody asked me to boyfriend is gone CN
destroy me more ghetto address but I Me
Mine SS in uh yes retreat you diversity
Corazon get your God
catch you and Oh God
see sit down money
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the California to me Pilate asked or not
lies your move us for more amazing
Oh Harry doesn't go to Seoul Busan yeah
it's a yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
elbows or food a steak and a Korea's
bunion due tomorrow
a little cold sore
but la promesa llamo man I don't make
sure my elbow died or gonna go
shangri-la
oh yes yes thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yama console the you are enormous
yo no se see my let's see today or for a
beer a song
[Music]
tengo miedo never scott it there he then
told Roy today
the master udon means amigos gotta bow
[Laughter]
i momentos Enka quisiera mejora Hartmann
hear on Karima Yabo's let me fellow
[Laughter]
battle me so go somewhere else in order
to the phone me Kareem you followed
order that we will star
[Music]
Oh God
right third party too far
[Laughter]
Paloma negra Paloma negra
don't know
you know whoever told me on Monday
see to scurry see us you'll get them all
Booya
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
before teeth ah yes
[Music]
[Laughter]
Yoga
[Music]
Oh what up yes thank you thank you you
see my gracias thank you very much Maria
chilling Basma he can ask it is really
an honor to be here with all of you guys
thank you very much for the opportunity
to all the organizers and
congratulations on 15 years of the
screening of real women have we just
loved it
we're very proud of being latina and
being the Haqqanis 100% McKenna's thank
you for being here with us tonight
thank you and this can be sung for sure
all of you out here before if you like
please sing it with us we love this song
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh yeah yeah yeah gone by Norris
[Music]
nor settle this and I nearly blew Engel
yeah me men go s a lunatic at the end
cielito II know I know
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
candles the grantee kourindou look for a
soul is uh yeah yeah yeah god I know
your head Oh God
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
que bonito suppose tienes live a hood
it's a so sick house never who they
start to take us we need to so push DNA
they use my kidding me da Pharaoh Sifu
no lost a class pero si - no lost the
toss PC get up or apollyon
[Music]
so little sir
Bastardo Flavius kiss Yuto best sorry to
love you quisiera mulligan yas a little
heated
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
we must make it gonna piss off
[Music]
see put of boredom it is per se us
you're they gonna save us all
you're they consider us all see put up
over there man
you're not do fresca Casa the old
friends coca-cola so to press to Meco de
song
how come you let me wrestle
PETA see
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Marty's
[Music]
come
[Music]
[Music]
see see see
Claro que si Osato Caro perkins en esta
cancion smoo popularise muy the
Cherisher a welcome on Mexico and it is
you're gonna enjoy this song all of you
know it
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
una Cucaracha LaCava vamonos paramita
era a pasar la temporada una Cucaracha
Pinta levy who Allah Colorado vamonos
para meteor ah ah pasar la temporada
Cucaracha Cucaracha yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Lama Vandana Clara Encino severe
amaretto to the me la llamada
vecina been Fred Nutella maman Dona
Clara Encino severe amaretto to the via
amara Donald Young up wouldn't come in
and put he'll no tiene por que le falta
last buffer on the garage and the garag
town
yon up will it coming on por que no
tiene hey les yes yes yes thank you very
much
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
throw Gary mementos Skinner's viento
only try will quote us so did I go
through a meal ma ma hill far away stop
a PLO Jacques de estas hablando mariachi
enthusiast Melancon MP para el Palenque
rebel star coalesce angry don't Apollo
unit chinoco katana busca more result
and
[Music]
the gun
yes Toyota me though became a dragon a
key Mexico Lindo a credo similar
me he gave me my Mexico
[Music]
la fiesta de la tierra Mia is Allegra
Cole canciones to Marietta for Ventura
to ps4 either muchas gracias thank you
please welcome to the stage singer
Lupita Infante
granddaughter of iconic Mexican film
actor and singer Pedro Infante this SSL
is a place of our mariachi Linda Russo
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
son-in-law viscosity enemy alpha reverse
Blancas proton a las casas casitas ibaka
de la fere romania
[Music]
Oh trouble neither
sapa to the recipe level they say that
they welcome
buzzer Maserati also Marcelino to pursue
his anima sake but I said
[Music]
vámonos a la Clara vamos a ganar el
camino de manana tenemos cassava tierno
bonito it to sing that colorada quiero
castes BM vena that when the viola cell
bodies go become honest there
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the
[ __ ]
[Music]
but
[Music]
[Applause]
so did everybody get those lyrics kind
of well basically it's talking about the
mestizos and how I'm gonna take you out
to dance and I'm gonna get you some nice
shoes so you better get ready so we
could dance to an $30.00 so this next
song that I'm gonna perform my
grandfather sing it and one of the songs
he sang and it talks about it's called
La Feria de las Flores the fair of the
flowers so it's gonna talk about horses
and having my big gun cuz of course it's
very much alright and it's talking about
this beautiful flower that I see and
that I want to take it home and put it
in my garden and it's a woman
[Music]
megusta can turn el viento for a gavel
on Miss confidence evil okay yo siento
papa leaders
but give in a political order
my seller okis mm [ __ ] Nick Walker
case a method a yes he said Rita
America's greatest ever and Myka by your
letting go revenues III go peacefully
[Music]
is a key I unit Rosso Danya there's love
Lord let me some more
[Music]
[Applause]
so this part says I don't care if the
flower has a gardener if I see it I'm
gonna cut it and I'm gonna take it home
yeah some of the guys out there like
yeah I know what you're talking about
young khodro Kiara Curatola yo la Vera
VSIP Romero
[Music]
Yahoo okay the rola honking your little
another me
you see son never really narrow possible
a very good basa thank you very much
thank you so this is my last song and
it's a very special song it's called
cien anos meaning 100 years and it's
very special because my grandfather sang
this song and popularized it in Mexico
and he is also celebrating his
centennial this November so it would be
his hundredth birthday November 18 if he
was still with us but we're still gonna
celebrate him and his music so here is
cien anos
[Music]
but son I'm in love conquer and in
diferencia the sawhorse nice' ta-da boy
lady I don't see on me
every sink of every had our definition
get million
ito Tamiya Murray Gouda
better than me mother when I asked on
Ibiza servin get me all the way past and
Ben's not candy despot SEO let us go
he's seen embargo see there's only the
one existence here ECB boss cien anos
cien anos being funny
[Music]
meadow la Stella feed our servants Ella
siren come on I can do this but I see
you meta sky we see them but Urkel
singers much lesser firm exe spends e ec
v bosse and I'm yours CN on yours
EMP
[Music]
muchas gracias Thank You Mariachi
Linda's mexicana
very special things to the Academy for
having us here enjoy the film
[Applause]
that's right
[Applause]
you
Lord s party Joe
[Applause]
thank you so much I have to tell you
that I find you here in the audience of
the Academy very touching
thank you for coming and we also want to
thank Tamara cheese Linda's mexicanas
for the performance as well as Lupita
Infante great other thanks are in order
for the Getty foundation for making this
moment possible and thank the Academy
for being a partner and is very
successful effort today we're
celebrating the exhibition of real women
have curves a film base but this year
that is also been marked the end gave us
a taste of what the beginning of a
feature latina film industry would be
like in the US and that was 15 years ago
that she made this film we are patient
people
we are patient but we're also very
tenacious we're not going to give up
until we have a place
[Applause]
personally I would like to honor
Lupe Ontiveros honor her for her career
and constant support of Latino and
Latina filmmakers she's watching us I
think it was no wonder that in 2002 in
the film premiered at Sundance it won
the three main prizes one of them was
the audience award which meant that the
majority of the people who voted were
women present during this film let us
keep on voting let's not stop voting and
enjoy this wonderful film thank you
now we're going to screen a trailer from
kiss of the Spider Woman the film that
will screen on Monday in honor of the
recently deceased actor by wrinkle who
we interviewed for the Academy Pacific
Standard Time la la project and we will
then begin the tonight's feature film
screening of real women have curves
after the feature the film's publicist
Academy Award member evet Rodriguez will
be moderating the panel with the
filmmakers thank you so much for being
here come to the other screenings
[Applause]
[Applause]
hello everyone wasn't that amazing
can you believe that was 15 years ago
this week when real women have curves
was released in theaters 15 years ago
exactly how many how many of us want
more real women have curves to be made
today
this film was so impactful I I'm a
publicist and I worked on the Hispanic
campaign for the film and I remember
when I saw it I just couldn't believe I
was being reflected my family my stories
I so appreciated an America Ferrara's
portrayal I related to her on so many
levels as I'm sure a lot of you do so
it's sad that it's been 15 years and I
know that the women that I'm going to
call on the stage here that together
they can make a difference and maybe we
can change some things here in Hollywood
they are that powerful and and not only
it's unfortunate that we've had ten days
or I don't know how many days a storm of
stories coming out of Hollywood and how
women are being treated and which is
absolutely deplorable but what I say is
how about women of color and how about
people of color and how about Latinos
how are we being treated in Hollywood
I'd like to for that to also be an
internal conversation this is the time
we need more real women have curves and
with so I'm going to call up these
lovely ladies I'm first I would like to
call up Jose FINA Lopez the writer of
the play and film co-producer and
mannequin manager Marilyn Atlas
producer Effie Brown director Patricia
Cardozo
and actors Ingrid Alou Soledad st.
Hilaire and America Ferrera isn't this
beautiful women I would like to start
with what Safina lopez this is your baby
you that started off as a play it's semi
autobiographical and I would love for
you to share you know your your story
your journey of getting this play this
film made and really did you set out to
to tackle the issues that this film
tackles because there are so many it's
it's incredible and even the play has
more because the play deals with
immigration as well this story really
started when I was in high school I went
to Los Angeles County High School for
the Arts and I had a wonderful theater
teacher who pulled me aside and it
started with me being embarrassed to
wear leotards we were supposed to do
chorus line and I couldn't wear so I was
wearing shorts and she said why aren't
you wearing leotards and then I told her
and I was embarrassed of my body and
then she said well you know I've been
wanting to have this conversation with
you if you're really serious about being
an actress you have to lose weight
because no one will ever cast you as the
ingenue if you don't lose weight and I
started to cry because I was always
afraid to even think that I could be an
actor because I thought oh you have to
be wait because I equated being white
with being beautiful you know and so
when she told me that I cried and then
she started crying with me and she said
you know and I I said I feel so bad
telling you this because I was told the
same thing and so I'm not telling you
because I think you should change but
this is the way the business were
I guess you know men want to play the
heroes and all the stories and so I
guess the women have to be thin enough
for them to be lifted up into their arms
to walk into the sunset because men get
to be the heroes of all the stories and
when she said that I said I was like
okay and so I remember I tried to lose
weight for like two weeks then I got
really angry right I did like I was
trying to say you know I took her advice
I was 18 years old and then at some
point I really angry and I said you know
first they'll tell me that I have to
lose weight then they'll tell me to
change my name because my name you know
my dear host Michael Safina Lopez right
that's no so Mexican right he doesn't
get more Mexican than that so then I
said they're gonna tell me to change my
name and then they're gonna tell me why
don't you change your hair color and
then they're gonna tell me why don't you
change your story and then why don't you
not talk about the fact that you were
undocumented and then at some point I
said God if I have to give up everything
of Who I am to be an actor then there's
nothing left of me so then instead of me
saying you know what I should change the
no [ __ ] you society you should change
right and and that's where like what I
hate came and I think we're all sitting
here because there was that 18 year old
girl it said there's something wrong
Society not me because I was born
Mexican I you know that's that's how
that's I was born this way right I was
born to parents who didn't have an
education so there were working-class
people who were dignified so why should
I be ashamed so everything that I was
told to be ashamed of I was like I
didn't do anything wrong and I'm told to
to hide to be quiet to apologize for Who
I am when I did nothing wrong and there
was something inside of me that said no
if there are no stories about chunky
girls getting laid or being heroes then
I'm gonna write those stories you know
and it doesn't matter if I don't get to
be an actor because somebody else will
someone else will get to live this dream
and so I set out to start writing and I
wrote real women have curves because I
worked in a sewing factory I was
undocumented for 13 years so when I got
my green card I decided that I was never
gonna hide anymore because I was tired
of being a shadow of being ashamed that
I was undocumented because like a paper
determines that you're a human being and
you believe it right you know I'm so
proud of the dreamers because now they
don't take that [ __ ] they're like no
we're human beings it was not our fault
but at that time you know and so for me
writing this play was an affirmation of
my humanity of saying no I'm a human
being and I don't know what I did wrong
and I refuse to apologize damn it I have
my life has value women's lives have
value women's stories have value and I'm
so sick of Hollywood tellin us
constantly that women's lives don't
don't matter that our stories don't
matter because I've been in this
business for thirty years right and you
would think that you know I this is a
beautiful movie right but I could have
gotten ten more done by now but yeah
seriously like how many we've been
waiting for so long right I really hope
this explodes and I hope it eventually
gets to racism because you know I can't
say that I've been harassed like you
know because I have the talent you know
when you have the talents like nobody
can tempt you with anything right and uh
but but the racism that I've experienced
for 30 years I'm sick of it so I think
this story unfortunately is so relevant
because it's about women's lives
mattering the fact they matter you know
that's such a audacious statement and
anyway I went on and on thank you the
director of the film when was the first
time that you met but the host Athena
did you see her play prior to I'm
reading the script did you know about
this story and what was your experience
with real women have curves coming to
you well it came to me a few times
before the movie got made and the first
time is when I was going to UCLA to film
school and I went to see a play called
simply Medea and downtown to LA Theatre
Works and I just loved it I remember
that I sat in the first row with my
friends one of them is here Francisco
and with her of my classmates and I was
just laughing so much because I could
identify so much with that character
with the character of the play and you
know it always you know I just that kept
you know I kept thinking about that and
then he so many years later I after I
graduated from UCLA and my student film
have one is to an Academy Award and I
was getting a lot of attention like a
producer come and told me are you
during this project and he sent me the
play and I read and I loved it and then
we talked about it but nothing happened
and then more years went by and I like
years and years keep coming back and
then I got a call from a producer I have
made a descendent feel festival Jim
stark and when I had charged some of
some of my chores and he told me you
know HP is looking for a director for
this movie called real women have curves
and I went and I interview a lot of you
know I had to go through the whole
interview process that you go when you
are a director you're also like an actor
you know you have to go you have to dis
you you know it's a lot of work you have
to go and met the producer and then the
executive is the president of the studio
so I went through the whole thing and
you know I guess I just love this story
so much and I can even the Xhosa fine
and I like we come from different
background I come
you know from Columbia and I came here
as a grownup you know I just identified
so much with the story the mother and
the daughter and and I loved all day
like Mexican culture so and the husband
is Mexican and he saw murder and so
that's kind of how it happened and then
they hire me fortunately and the
wonderful Effie Brown here was a pretty
user
yeah thank you um America it's hard to
believe this is your first film you're
so incredible in it it's so impactful I
had done a month before I got cast in
this I had a wrapped a Disney Channel
movie called got it kick it up you know
it they know it but in fact real women
have curves came out before gotta kick
it up aired on the Disney Channel so the
first time my name was on a screen and
certainly in the theaters was was real
first time I saw myself on a screen was
at the Sundance Film Festival in the
library to a packed house and a standing
ovation to this film congratulations now
how has playing Ana impacted your life
both professionally and personally that
is a really big question and and you
know in short in all the ways I mean I
could have never known that it's 17 you
know being a you know the one of six
children to a single Honduran immigrant
mother growing up in the valley where
months went by where we didn't have warm
running water or running water at all or
electricity you know having this dream
of being an actress coming from where I
came from you know people my own family
my friends my teachers people would say
to me like that's very unlikely for you
and I you know with the naivete of a
young person because I had been told
there was nothing I couldn't do I
believed it and I you know I could have
even then no knowing in the moment that
it was so special and my dream was
coming true I could have never
understood them the way I do now what an
anomaly this film was and the fact that
I had been in the right place at the
right time at the right age to get to
take on this role this film and and it
set the bar for me I mean
I remember going traveling the world
with this film and seeing people of all
ages all ethnicities male/female you
name it just coming up to me and saying
that's me I'm that girl and for that to
be my first experience with acting with
with film to realize that it wasn't just
about you know being an actress and
getting to make movies but telling
stories that reflected people's lives
back at them it changed everything for
me and it and it made me realize that
that I could have a career that meant
something bigger than just myself and my
own dreams of my own aspirations and and
and it is so painful sometimes to think
about how little has happened for Latina
women in film or just people of color or
communities of color since this film and
the way that it was received but but I
think what keeps me going and I think a
lot of the women and people of color I
know going is is that if we don't break
down the doors that we can break down
then we're not doing justice to the
people coming behind us and I always and
also I'll say quickly that not just real
women have curves but working my first
film role with Lupe Ontiveros changed my
life and it's so hard to not have her
here with us today we do have her family
here our family is here which were so
grateful day hello better family but
working working with Lupe opened my eyes
up from the very beginning about how
people with enormous talent could go
their whole careers and never get the
real chance to express the entirety of
their talent and and and when when it
when it gets hard or when it feels you
know when it feels like are we moving in
the right direction are we breaking
those doors down is it getting
I think about looping all the time and
that's why we're gonna get her a star on
the Walk of Fame right yeah we're gonna
nominate her in May and hopefully
they'll approve the nomination and then
we'll raise the funds to get her a star
on the Walk of Fame because even the
Academy forgot to include her in the
eulogy yeah so we gotta give her a star
anyway
join me in that so working on this film
and working with the people that I got
to work with completely defined for me
the type of career I wanted to have in
the type of career that I saw as
possible for myself thank you I think it
is so important women we must support
each other and we must lift each other
up and Marilyn who met a young Josefina
and read the play and actually were very
instrumental in pushing when she didn't
want to push anymore right to get this
to get this the story to the producer
that finally sold it right to HBO tell
us a little well a little bit God tell
the story I was producing plays in 1996
and someone asked me if I would read a
young playwright I read two plays one
was called simply Maria and the other
was real women have curves the writer
Moe Safina wrote simply Maria when she
was 17 years old and real women have
curves at 19 I was completely blown away
by her emotional intelligence the
complexity of the characters and the
themes that she explored and even though
my background was in thought was
completely different I was very moved by
what she wrote and I met with her and I
said I am going to get this play made as
a movie you know in the end this was
1996
somehow or another and I think it's part
of her genius she was able to find in
this specific what's Universal and you
know it just I was very very moved by it
several years later I was lucky to meet
George Loulou who's in New York and he
also from a very different background
the
play resonated in him very strongly as
it didn't me and when I knew HBO finally
thankfully fell in love with the script
and wanted to make it given a lot of the
standards in Hollywood I knew it would
be difficult to find a young actress to
play Ana and I called a couple of people
and America's picture and resume wound
up on my desk and I knew unequivocally
the same thing when I read this play
that she was destined to play Ana and
casting was seeing people in Texaco
Texas and Mexico and all over and I just
knew so it was so moving the first time
I was on the set to see America that
completely embodied this character that
had been living in me and Ho Safina for
at least seven or eight years thank you
sp tell us about hi so when did real
women have curves come to you what point
did you get involved no I got involved
um George Levu there was a woman named
Maude Nadler who I think we need to give
okay get let's listen but like um she
isn't yoga teacher now she said [ __ ] you
to the industry and excuse my language
but and she is having a fabulous life
being a yoga teacher but but let's give
it but she was a champion not only for
this movie but for like American
Splendor sugar Maria full of grace and I
feel that having champions
she was gotta give a Tai Chi she fought
the good fight and she really did some
amazing she really championed some
really amazing work and I previously did
a film for them called stranger inside
and and that's how it came to me and I
think it was I got on was it right
before you
I feel yes right before cuz we did that
whole and putting it together so that's
how it sort of organically came together
Maude Nadler she had a real
for putting together dysfunctional
functional families and and one of the
things I mean I just want to just say it
was this was a second movie ever
produced and you were really it's it was
real it was hard and it was lovely like
remember I just America was the first
actress that we saw and I think we cast
for another like eight months and then
we're like we saw because we couldn't
believe that we found the right person
at first that's the first time do you
know what I mean like it but everything
really like those are like the little
stories so that you know that that sort
of moved me and also doing you know and
your beautiful beautiful play that
became a wonderful screenplay and
realized by you and you all being in it
it was it's really it's not really being
very articulate but it just moved me I
mean that scene where you know when that
we I wasn't in it okay you know what I
mean I'm like I wasn't that wasn't me
but like that scene was one of the
scenes that when we first got the script
of like this is gonna be a very
monumental moment and and it was and
seeing it again for 15 years later and
to that I was going to talk about that
scene that exhilarated scene and ask
Ingrid and sort of that to share I mean
the dynamic dynamic the presence of all
of you on the screen it looks like
you're having the time of your life like
we all don't wanted to jump in there and
join you what was it like behind the
scenes and what was it like to shoot
that particular scene all I thought was
because if you notice we're really white
you know want me to take off her clothes
so all I could remember was oh my god we
asked the director could we have some
makeup good could they put some makeup
because we're so white and the director
but please take care of those no no no
no I want it all to be real you know I
want it the way you are
but I remember that it was very
uncomfortable it was really hard it
looks like a lot of fun well we had a
practice and it was just really hard and
I remember we were rehearsing we were
rehearsing and then we would bring in
the the cruel and at one point I don't
remember I just remember taking off my
clothes and there were two all these
people and I didn't realize and after a
walk you then you get comfortable but it
was hard guys because you see how is why
well she had the sexy clothes by them oh
yeah you're sure I'm hiding an artist
from yes I was geriatric sexy I still
have it
he's gonna go on eBay so here I go to
the audition and I bring my mom with me
matter of fact my mommy's yeah she's not
an actress
but she comes as a mobile is called
because I need carpool come on
so she comes over with me and I go to do
my addition and then I come out and then
I said okay so my mom went in there and
I don't know what happened in there so
she comes to Howard and all of a sudden
she's in the movie but anyway after that
after I left and I got the part
I call my daughter and I said oh my god
Sibella they offered me a part in the
movie but I have to get naked and as you
said alright what should I do
no mom you cannot accept that no my
friends are gonna see you naked hell no
I'm the night look I'm sorry already say
yes
so so then I I did it and I have a lot
of fun oh my god that movie was like
hilarious I mean every day is like not
even go to work I mean it's like awesome
I wish I could do it all the time but
then one time my mom was sitting behind
me and you're not right what's wrong
with you
come on this is a movie come on and then
Patricia comes over and she said what
are you doing Soledad I said well I'm
telling my mom what you know she's gonna
Roger I am the director you are the
actor okay so she is my actor I'm like
oh I'm sorry but oh my god that movie
this was awesome I mean every time I see
it I like I I saw though I know the
whole script it's like I'm telling the
words and everything but it's so awesome
because he shows that it stills
happening that people are not letting
their kids their daughters thought of
the University because they have to stay
home and they have to help the family so
everything that we saw in there is true
I mean it happens I mean not even when I
said for Hispanics Latinos but
everywhere it happened all the races
have it in one way or another so but
thank you guys it was great thank you
I think I have room front can I mention
something please DuPont to mention about
the scene like they getting naked scene
you know when I you know when I actually
I did go and see the play and to me it
was the most difficult scene in the in
the movie because I wanted to really
show the women to be beautiful and you
know I'm not not to not to try to be
like for tasks you know because it could
be so I worked really hard with someone
who is in the audience
Jim - no where are you - first Jim - no
enemies Joe well there is a fabulous DP
he killed it an amazing job because you
know if it was not for Jim the movie
wouldn't be what it is you know and I
you know I said have you noticed that
how beautiful the print is is a new
printer that that pilot was it's
crashing the lady panel eyes are giving
her seat for the white if it was not for
for these amazing cinematographer this
movie wouldn't be what it is because I
was just looking at the brain and it's
just you know everything is so real and
so beautiful and you know and I remember
when I when I interview many
cinematographers we were before
interview Jim and many of them told me
you know we want to make it look like
you know like really ugly like a
sweatshop I guess that's really still a
gang film and I was like no no but you
know to me it's a beautiful place you
know I just want to show the beauty of
East Los Angeles well please and then I
focus in my talk refer incredibly
talented that you know I agree had the
same sensibility so tell us about how
the moderator I check the moderator
well directing the day before we shot
the scene I said to Patricia so how's it
gonna go
is everything okay and she said oh yes
they picked out all their underwear they
really
like their underwear they're very happy
it's gonna be great it was what was the
question the process of making this
movie for me was you know Patricia and I
would walk around Boyle Heights just
kind of on our days off taking pictures
looking you know looking at things we
was it me and Brigitte or you and I who
found the sewing factory we were just
walking down the street and it was like
here's the location right here it's it
was that kind of process and Patrice you
would say okay here's the beautiful
mural that we so we figure out how to
you know how to somehow incorporate
every beautiful spot and in that part of
town
that's like for me that's it's a
distilled version of Boyle Heights and
in a live for example like the pharmacy
scene where Anna goes to buy the condoms
that was not in this creep and I found
the pharmacy and I said I need to see
this pharmacy it's right next to my
theater everyone I guess it is something
in this pharmacy so what can we do like
a condom and then like right to hoe
Safina you need to write a scene where
she was accountable so so I have a
question for America please okay America
remember that scene they way you had
well disrobing seen how tough it was can
you and can you talk about that day what
what are we talking about remember how
you were menstruating that day and
you're like how the hell did the scene
what it took welcome to the naked see
the disrobing scene oh I was we had to
convince you you don't remember first of
all you got grown-ass women saying it
was scary so how do you think it fell to
a seventeen-year-old well where did you
get the courage because not many people
could do what you did it's ID that day
when I was at that moment cuz but these
are now were like what are we gonna do
she doesn't want to take every clothes
she's okay I didn't want to take no she
was fabulous
oh it's to me all right uh-oh
I remember actually when I first read
the script and then I gave it to my mom
to read and my mom had the same she's
like you're gonna take your clothes off
I was like mom it's it's a movie it's
the lead part in a movie like who writes
movies for people like me of course I'm
gonna do it and I think I was probably
even more uncomfortable doing that
really awkward sexy yeah then taking off
the clothes with them but what I do
remember about that day was like coming
in with like a robe and the whole crew
being on the other like you imagine
being 17 years old and taking your
clothes off in front of like an all man
crew okay
there was um there was a lot but also
list of speakers you were 17 and 17 year
olds can't be naked in a movie because
that's a different thing
you were actually had on clothes notice
I don't get me arrested right let's not
get me arrested okay thank you very much
what I remember is so I got a story
about a bee
if we're gonna get it chilly you want to
talk about how you brought me with that
brown leather coat I don't know what and
only that guess I did write that brown
leather coat and you know what I took it
back and I go I still have that brown
okay
no I do there was no but I'd let me
answer the question because what I
remember is that I walked in that day
was like a robe and I won't need it
everybody about leave behind the thing
and it was like taking off the thing and
then call action we do the scene and
then I put the robe back on and then I
like take four I was like I don't need
the robe like my take four was like it's
fine we're fine I'm fine
I possible working in the estrogen while
I would love to continue and I'm sure
they do too we do have to say goodbye
and thank you all so much for being here
thank you so much
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you
you